yeah but um because you remember Wolfman
Jack
um back in the 70s he was the DJ the DJ
remember Wolfman like this guy okay hey
this is Wolfman Jack on WKRP that
remember you sound like Wolfman Jack all
right so it's cool so so because your
voice was you used to smoke cigarettes
or it's not that
it's not that
um and I've gone back and forth about
being like insecure about it
um and and proud of like it being very
distinctive and and and and trademark
um in in moments when I was feeling
insecure about it like feeling that it
deteriorates and it's getting worse
um I found a voice doctor to go and and
look and maybe I thought maybe I have
like nodules on my vocal cords like
maybe this and that like maybe is it
from a stunt that you did back in the
day maybe I've done damage to it like uh
with you know huffing nitrous oxide I
thought it might be part of it
um the uh voice doctor put a camera up
and and he said that I'm using to speak
I'm using like the muscles above my
vocal cords which is making this uh you
know weird thing and I was like wow like
you're telling me after everything I've
been through I just suck at talking and
that's really it's that simple did you
get a second opinion
um I got a vocal coach who served as a
second opinion and tried to teach me and
he said the same thing yeah I think so
so because I've known you for a long
time I may not know known you but I've
known of you for a long time and I would
see you on different things but you
never used to talk like that okay did
you I mean in the last five years
looking back at old maybe 20 years ago
I'm talking about I mean you've been
around for a while so yeah I think I get
old footage I think you always sound I
mean I can't tell yes you've always done
you've always had that iconic voice I
mean I remember
you know running into you 20 years ago
how long have you guys known each other
for nine years we've been working
together for nine years awesome yeah but
but you would you would watch him just
like I would watch him but he and his
voice wasn't like it was a little and it
was but but it's not a cigarette thing
no it's not a cigarette thing oh wow
because Vegas they they call it Vegas
throat I don't know if you ever heard of
that it's where you live in Vegas too
long you start talking like this what's
going on because they're yeah it's the
air conditioning [ __ ] like that yeah
yeah so um I mean hey you know what I've
worked with the vocal coach who was who
was making some progress and teaching me
to speak like you know like a little bit
more
who's happening and uh I just don't
[ __ ] and as long as it doesn't hurt I
mean it'll hurt you drink hot tea and
some honey and stuff
she says don't [ __ ] change it she
just when I was when I was working with
the vocal coach my girl she wasn't happy
she said [ __ ] this is [ __ ] you
can also gargle with warm salt water
right okay that's pretty good you can
also gargle these nuts
just kidding yeah dude it's called
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on Amazon and type in Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're at
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah yeah
bad dude